>> The thing that I find most useful in
trying to understand the folk theorem and, and what
it says and how it works is a thing that I call a two-player plot. I don't know
if other people have other names for it, but
this, this concept is out and, and often discussed.
I just don't know what it's called [LAUGH]. But
here's the idea of it, it's a really simple idea.
>> It's like a folk plot.
>> It is a, it is a folk, a folk plot, right,
I don't know who invented this plot. So here's what we're going to do,
remember this prisoner's dilemma game. We've
got two players, there's Smoove and Curly.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And, what we're going to do, is
we're, there's a bunch of joint, actions that
they can take. So Smoove cooperates and
Curly defects, or they both defect, or they
both cooperate, or one defects defect cooperate
in the other direction. So what we're going to
do is for each of those joint outcomes,
each of those joint action choices. I'm going to
plot a dot, put a dot on a two-dimensional plot, where
this is the Smoove axis, and this is the Curly axis, okay.
>> Okay.
>> So cooperate-cooperate, remember from the
prisoner, prisoner dilemma payoffs, is minus
one, minus one. So I put a dot at minus one, minus one.
Defect, defect. Is it minus six, minus six? Cooperate defect is it minus
nine zero? And defect cooperate, is it zero minus nine? . So do
those four points make sense to you? Do you understand like the idea?
>> They do.
>> It may not be so obvious why we do, do it this
way, because as you have told us, the matrix is all you need.
>> Mm-hm.
>> But this is really just representing the matrix in another form.
But it actually is sort of losing some information. Because these dots
don't tell us what the relationship is in terms of if, if
one player keeps the same action and the other player changes to
a different action. The matrix captures that but
this plot doesn't anymore, it's kind of washed out.
>> I see.